okay welcome to the second video I still
have some closing remarks to make about
about the Slav I didn't quite manage in
the first video and I'm a bit surprised
how much time this actually took um okay
I was some at this point where it's a
choice between Knight f3 and and going
for e3 one important thing is if you
want to go for the e3 lines it makes
much sense to to play Knight c3 year
first of course you could play Knight f3
with the intention of going for the e3
lines but this gives black extra options
black now can play Bishop f5 or Bishop
g4 which are both very solid white can
play for for slight edge here but it's
it's very tiny and it's also very slow
and positional type of game if you go
for this move order and then III this is
very helpful because you don't have the
knight on f3 this has two consequences
and the move Bishop g4 while playable
just well goes into thin air you could
just play a three for instance a Bishop
f5 um you have a good response with CD 5
c5 Queen b3 and now um b7 is just
attacked and also d5 needs to be covered
somehow so the natural move for black
Queen b6 can be just answered by am
taking off d5 you know so this is
a problem like needs to reach iridium
which is well possible but of course not
what black intended to do White has a
slight advantage she because of the
little development okay III isn't isn't
ideal because of the bishop but still a
slight a slight edge so this Knight c3
III moves water so limits a lot the
possibilities that that black has if you
are satisfied with this line for
instance you really should use this move
order because there's not much black can
do to to avoid it you can go Asics of
course a g6 but it's no way a comparison
to to the lines with Knight f3 and
taking on c4 which is really a huge body
of theory a four we should f5 and set
our Bishop f5 black might go Bishop g4
96 it's a lot of stuff well just in
general I'd like a like 95 m to go f3
and ie form in the future but it's it's
it's a lot to study um okay I guess this
was the main outline of the Slav let's
now have a quick look at the Queens
gambit accepted like take some take some
c4 yeah here white basically has got two
options recapturing the pawn after
playing III or reform and I think white
really should take advantage of the fact
that he's played second c4 and I played
before him it's just the most aggressive
way to to combat this now black has
mostly we have four moves actually it's
a lot of choice we can play both
sensible night moves or yeah the
sensible born moves let's start off with
Knight f6 it's this always leads to the
same kind of positions it's just a
simple line where y term enjoys the nice
center so it's got some central
advantage nice development and yeah it's
got more space this is really a sharp
line like much go for a long castle so
it's a it's it's a fight but in general
white is considered to be to be slightly
better here um the knight move knight c6
is also possible well I'll just give a
quick overview Knight f3 to cover D for
Bishop g4 d 595 actually this line looks
a little bit like a chigorin defense
it's a little bit a mix of a great scam
but accepted and she going there
actually there's more than one line
which is good for white but this is just
one I can recommend
okay get the pawn back end enjoy the
slide central advantage um like because
other options here are c5 it's not
played very often the main line man is
d5 is just good to advance in the senton
than he six Bishop c4 takes Knight takes
Knight takes Bishop takes and so on
white also has got some slip of the
arrows going here and some nice
advantage with the strong bishop on on
d5 so it's actually useful here because
what is really threatening Bishop takes
f7 now
okay black will attend this I guess will
Snite not some we're not
6 or something yeah white white is just
just a little bit better here extra pawn
in the center and strong Bishop um main
movie 5 and this January leads to
positions like this uniform uniform
takes this would be for check other
options 96 very often it did it comes to
a position where white at some point
gets back at the pawn on d4 this is just
a sample and this has been popular
recently yeah just stop here it's
already moved 14 where white has got
some thread on e7 and yeah and general
white often gets the pawn back later and
it's just a position where white has
some space advantage with the pawn on e5
um this is not little to study it so
it's a bit it's a bit of effort to to
look at this but okay the queen's gambit
accepted this is really a serious option
so i recommend you for other main main
option of course is go night at 3 at e3
but this is just not as aggressive ends
also a little bit of theory to to look
at um the next line and the most
important arguably besides the sloth is
e6 actually 6 is the classical way of
for defending the queen's gambit um but
it's from repertoire point of view it's
it's not that much of an effort to study
i think the lines and slur for instance
if you want to play in an aggressive
fashion against the Slav you need to
study much more in comparison to to e6
buzzes it's also due to the fact that
you can play Nancy through here and not
have committed the knight on f3 for
instance after d4 d5 Knight f3 other
lines I'm going to show are just not
working
a black now has some couple of options
from the most common option is Knight f6
still especially on a little bit lower
level than then world-class other
possible lines Bishop e7 which we will
study last here but which is supported
and c6 is possible the triangle
variation on here actually it's it also
depends on what kind of lines you like
to allow and you don't like to allow I
recommend to play d4 here it's just yeah
the toughest move for black like John
then takes only 4 and gives us check
white sacrifices upon here but he's got
very nice compensation in form of the
two bishops F 1 and especially the one
on before it's very strong it will
prevent black from Catholic short for a
while or first black to make other
concessions and especially the dark
squares are really weak this line maybe
is theoretically okay for black but it's
difficult to play but it's not something
you can just play off hand you need to
study a couple of more museum take it a
little bit bit further in the theory um
other idea here of course instead of E
for this play Knight f3 or e3 this is of
course really related to to to the Slav
lines if you play III for instance and
black plays 9006 you're just back into
the Marin but of course black might try
f5 and if you have some line there that
you like for instance an aggressive
option here is to play g4 which is
Sharma
a wizard which is quite sharp and then
you can also simply go for a three-year
other possibility is 9 f3 which has got
the advantage that it basically prevents
the Stonewall set up because f5 is just
bad because of Bishop f4 I won't go and
you can look it up it's horrible for
black hmm but Knight f3 allows black to
to take here and hold on to the porn
actually or play very notable variation
if you have something ready there you
can also play Knight f3 but it's a
general it's a sharp stuff black usually
plays the setup if he's into he plans to
play in really sharply um so you need to
have one life prepared for F or or
Knight f3 d3 but you have to look it up
it's really necessary to to do some
specific preparation here for instance
let's say you play III and it's playing
f5 if you don't then play without any
specific ID and Knight f3 Bishop b2 and
so on like equalizes easily you need to
have some some idea g4 as I just said on
another idea is Bishop d3 and Queen c2
93 they need to be some something
specific prepared him the easiest of
course in terms of move orders is just a
form but it's it's sharp black also of
course can go for um tomash defense
there because white what just takes and
here it's really now you don't have much
choice here what was the charge you just
need to go for the mainline there's just
nothing else if you want to want to play
for an edge which is the main and this
g3 interesting of midline is Bishop f4
you can
get this if you want to avoid the
mainland theory it's it's it's a bit
tricky and it's it's it's it's playable
g3 of course continues with mostly nine
of 6:52 there should be seven castles
castles and then White has to decide if
he wants to take on c5 or Bishop g5
which is the main rules I think
interesting also is b3 which is which is
tricky and not so well known but it's
got some drops of poison in it mm-hmm
but really there's no not much choice
everything else is just just okay for
black okay now a quick outline because
the time is running out for the second
video already what I will do against 906
I really it should suggest strongly
suggest two to play the exchange
variation CD 585 Bishop g5 and this also
applies for Bishop 87 after which I also
recommend to exchange on d5 and this
will be the next the third video which
will deal with both kinds of exchange
variations